for as long as human beings have walked
upon the earth and looked up to the
night sky at the vast inky darkness of
space we've pondered a particular
question over and over again are we
truly alone in the universe surely it
can't just be us right the stars and
planets stretch out so vastly beyond the
confines of our little blue world it
seems that there's at least enough room
up there for some other forms of life to
exist but if they do
if there's someone or something out
there would they be friend or foe would
an alien race be sympathetic to the
plights of humanity or would they
perhaps view us as a hostile threat
something to be wiped out before we had
a chance to do the same to them how
would such a race even go about
introducing itself to us with a swift
attack a grandiose emerging from space
or maybe they try something far subtler
a subterfuge observing us from a
distance watching
learning all well hidden in plain sight
to answer these questions posed
throughout the ages the ideas that have
inspired generations of science fiction
writers perhaps we should turn our gaze
away from the stars let's start our
story by instead looking at something
smaller something that might be the
exact opposite of the incalculable
vastness of space and all the mysteries
it holds this story like so many others
begins not up there among constellations
meteors and gas giants but in a small
rural town a satellite miles and miles
away from the busy lifestyle of the
nearest city a place where everyone
knows each other's face and where
someone no
something has been waiting
watching concealed in the one place no
one would expect now it's worth
remembering that when you live in a
small town being a local celebrity is
essentially just the same as infamy
saying that you're really famous in your
hometown can be like admitting that
you're considered the weirdest person in
your direct vicinity sometimes the
people with that mindset wind up
strutting around their tiny township in
the middle of nowhere under the
impression that they're god's gift to
every passerby other times they garner
odd looks and whispered stories from
anyone that spots them gary knew more
than his fair share of these types he
worked at a small family-owned
convenience store one of those places
that everyone in town shopped at now as
any retail worker will tell you no one
who works in a shop ever really likes
their job ultimately it's usually just a
way to get paid with the promise of one
day being able to wave goodbye to the
cycle of stacking shelves and manning
the cash register and so trapped in a
small town retail job usually stationed
in the one spot where he had to talk to
every customer that came through the
door gary had seen them all from the
ordinary and boring to the nasty and
unreasonable but on the other side of
that list were the people who were just
a little bit off those customers might
look a bit shady or act a bit strange
not enough to draw everyone's attention
but still enough to be noticed almost
like they felt uncomfortable in their
own skin one of the more infamous
customers that gary had encountered had
garnered one hell of a reputation with
his fellow employees they even had a
nickname for her the duchess as those
working in the shop knew her she seemed
mostly oblivious to other people around
her until she needed something and her
way of asking for help was certainly
strange to say the least sometimes she
might be rude or talk without specifying
which of the story's employees she was
talking to but then there were the times
where she seemed to be trying to engage
in conversation with gary or one of his
co-workers the duchess might start out
speaking with most of her own patterns
but would seem to try to copy the
cadence or dialect of whoever she
happened to be talking to she'd copy
accents echo back particular phrases or
even other languages like she was
mocking them or trying to mimic them
naturally every time she appeared in the
store gary and the rest of the staff ran
a mile or at least hid in the break room
out back until the owner of the store
told them to all get back to work but
among the employees caution was always
advised when approaching or providing
service to the duchess as if she could
snap at a moment's notice whenever he
saw her gary was reminded of his first
encounter with this particular customer
he had been unlucky enough to be filling
shelves when the duchess had appeared
out of nowhere she forced a basket into
his hands and instructed gary to follow
her around the shop and fill it with
items that she specified afterwards she
told him to carry her bags of shopping
outside and fill her car before she left
it was as though someone had altered
gary's job description to butler without
telling him no one fully understood why
she always acted so bizarrely there were
plenty of rumors circulating of course
ranging from the simple explanation of
she's from a different generation to the
more outlandish and wild theories while
he'd never fully believed in things like
that gary always joked that she was so
disconnected because she was actually
from another planet sure an alien
disguised as a human coming to do their
grocery shopping at a small town store
sounds impossible right well
maybe
around a week since his previous
encounter with the duchess gary noticed
another customer in the store who seemed
to be acting just as unusually it was a
man this time wiry and tall but hunched
over when the man had first come into
the store gary had spotted him muttering
to himself instantly trapped once again
behind the cash register he felt his
heart drop immediately assuming the man
might cause trouble as he shuffled all
around the store slinking through the
aisles gary could overhear him ranting
about
waffles the wire-framed man was
murmuring about waffles how they were a
pastry eaten for breakfast with syrup
how much humans enjoyed them
humans he hadn't said us he had
specifically used the word humans the
man quickly corrected himself with the
proper word almost as if he was teaching
himself how to speak naturally as anyone
else working retail would gary assumed
the man was inebriated as was often the
case no matter how strange someone in
the store was acting the staff would
ultimately forget all about them by the
time their long eight hour shift drew to
a close and they were eventually allowed
to go home but maybe it was becoming
more frequent because for some reason
gary couldn't help noticing even more
weird behavior from people all over town
sometimes it'd be somebody he knew a
neighbor a dog walker the one jogger
he'd see on their way back from the park
as he was heading home after work one
day they'd be themselves the next day
they'd be
well alien every time he spotted one it
seemed that another would appear the
very next day little did gary know
things were only due to get even
stranger still over the next month staff
from the store stopped showing up for
their shifts gary's manager was in
pieces trying to call his employees to
find out exactly why they weren't
notifying him about their unscheduled
absence each one never gave a clearer
answer the more of them stayed home the
longer gary found himself having to pick
up the slack and cover their shifts at
first when it was just an extra one or
two shifts a week he didn't mind so much
working more hours meant extra pay but
as more and more of his colleagues
seemed to disappear without a trace gary
started finding himself spending more
time at work than at home and feeling
pretty unhappy about it to say the least
after all what good is all that extra
overtime pay if you can't get any time
to spend it just as gary's exhaustion
from having to work so much was reaching
its peak taking so much of a toll that
he could barely stay awake at the
checkout that's when she appeared again
the duchess looked different this time
though and definitely not as the result
of a dramatic makeover immediately gary
noticed some kind of
growth swelling out from the duchess's
shoulder he didn't want to stare that
would be just as rude if not worse than
making a comment about it but he was
certain it hadn't been there before on
this particular day the duchess had
seemingly also decided to be more
unreasonable than usual instead of just
making gary carry her groceries out to
her car again she was insisting that he
bring them all the way back to her house
naturally gary told her what any
reasonable person would explaining
calmly that he couldn't leave the store
during his shift in the interest of
putting his own safety first
wrong move the duchess didn't seem to
understand the concept repeatedly
stating that this was
non-negotiable now when someone in
gary's line of work is faced with an
unreasonable and unusual request the
only person that can come to their aid
is their manager unfortunately a long
debate with the duchess was a battle
that gary's boss just couldn't win
eventually after talking in circles with
the duchess the store owner folded
telling his employee to do as she asked
while he stayed behind and watched the
cash register begrudgingly gary picked
up the duchess's groceries as she led
him out of the store big mistake
although it wasn't far and gary wasn't
really listening the strange customer
seemed to be talking about a gathering
she was hosting with a group of local
townsfolk waiting at her home sure that
sounds normal enough for some small town
folk when there's limited number of
people who live near you loving thy
neighbor usually becomes your only
option for socializing but gary wasn't
expecting the sight that awaited him
when he arrived at the duchess's house
just as she had said there was a huge
group of locals there all of them
milling around idly staring at gary with
wide unnerving eyes not blinking as he
carried the groceries indoors as if that
wasn't strange enough almost all of them
seemed to be sporting the same type of
growth as the duchess bulging out of
their shoulders or just visible under
shirt collars just like back in the
store gary tried to force himself not to
stare never letting his eyes linger for
too long on one of the silent staring
townsfolk or their strange protrusions
but maybe he would have been safer if
he'd stared maybe he would have noticed
the group of them huddling around him
shuffling closer while his back was
turned if he stared he might have
spotted the hands reaching out towards
him and he might even have seen what
looked like his co-workers the friends
he had from the store all huddled at the
back of the room as far as his boss knew
gary returned within a few minutes
followed shortly by the rest of his
staff the store owner spent a few
minutes angrily berating them for not
showing up to work on time not thinking
to question where they'd all been or why
they all came back to the store when
gary did each of his employees simply
stood there staring at him hanging off
every word like it was the first time
they heard a human being speak or like
they were learning how to the truth was
neither gary nor any of his colleagues
made it back to the store that day the
things that came back in their place
only looked like gary and the others on
the outside just like the other people
in the town more and more of them had
been acting strange speaking in odd
patterns and sporting strange growths on
their bodies no one knows how long it
took for everyone to be replaced some
mysterious organizations swept into town
a few weeks later a number of people or
the things that were disguised as people
all disappeared soon after any actual
humans that were left behind didn't
notice forgetting how many others used
to live in the town as if they had been
drugged with the local store closing its
doors and fewer people around most of
them packed their belongings and moved
on heading to live elsewhere eventually
the town fell silent if you were to pass
through there today you'd find nothing
but the remains of a community that
gradually changed into something alien
all that's left of the place now is a
ghost town you might even call it an
empty shell few people would ever really
understand what happened in that small
rural town even those who did know would
never admit to it the scp foundation is
like that as you may well know they're
shady secretive and would much rather
keep to themselves not unlike that group
of townsfolk actually well that is after
they'd each been replaced by an instance
of scp-3994
the thing no one dares to ask about
humanity looking up to the stars for so
many centuries is what if someone up
there was looking back at us what if for
the entire lifetime of our civilization
there's been a race of alien creatures
attempting to study us venturing to our
backwater small town of a planet and
taking the form of humans for some
nefarious purpose meet
scp-3994 that is if you haven't already
been acquainted with one of them they
could be anyone the local celebrity in
your small town a person who you pass on
the street every day even a wild animal
you see
scp-3994 refers to a race of
extraterrestrials beings not of our
world and a currently unknown number of
them have been catalogued by the scp
foundation
scp-3994s tend to hide in plain sight
through the use of convincing human skin
disguises or
shells well while these shells might
start by looking convincing in actual
fact they're far from perfect almost 70
percent of
scp-3994 shells experience some form of
rapid degradation and this causes the
imperfections in their disguises to
shine through a deteriorating human
shell usually results in a number of
physical deformities an
scp-3994 instance wearing its shell
might appear as someone with a limb that
twists and bends in an unnatural way but
showing no signs of actually noticing it
alternatively a person who seems to have
a skeleton that doesn't match their
external bodily proportions might also
be an extraterrestrial in hiding and
then there's the growths that some
scp-39
shells have these are severe
malformations that resemble
elephantiasis a medical condition that
causes certain areas of the body to
enlarge but just looking out for these
towels isn't a sure-fire way of spotting
one of these aliens not all their shells
have the same levels of decay in fact
the foundation has developed
sub-categories of
scp-3994 instances based on how
noticeable their shells are category a
are
scp-3994's whose shells are almost
impossible to detect practically
resembling human beings one-to-one on
the other side are the category c's
which are members of the same
extraterrestrial species without shells
and between them in category b are the
ones whose shells are showing signs of
decay another method the scp foundation
has used to detect instances of scp-3994
is speech in almost 40 percent of
conversations these aliens will attempt
to mimic the speech patterns of the
human they are conversing with this can
be as blatant as
scp-3994's echoing back elements of
speech as hard to replicate as regional
accents and dialects different languages
or specific phrases unique to the person
they're copying while in some instances
scp-3994s have shown difficulty with
grammar and syntax at first they seem to
be quick learners couple that with
almost perfect shells in category a and
these alien visitors could prove to be
formidable infiltrators researchers even
discovered telepathic communications
between instances eventually though all
scp-3994 shells do inevitably decay this
usually takes around a year as their
human disguises gradually dissolve until
the creature beneath is eventually
exposed that's where the various
protrusions misshapen body parts and
other signs of decay come from it's not
that
scp-3994's are intentionally walking
around with noticeable shells it's that
they can't prevent their shells from
eventually withering away until their
true self is put on display and what do
they look like under their disguises are
they tall slender grey-skinned beings
with long heads are they tiny little
green men piloting human-sized robot
suits could they even be bulbous
creatures of living calcium with huge
claws kept concealed and compressed in
skin suits with zippers hidden under
their hairlines well
no
to all of these that'd be terribly
cliche don't you think beneath their
rapidly decaying shells is a viscous
pulp-like substance of formless and
unquantifiable composition without their
disguises
scp-3994 have no regular shape no
skeleton or body structure underneath
each of them is just an indeterminate
mass that drags itself around aimlessly
so the one question that remains is
why
why come to earth why replicate and
replace innocent humans why spend so
much time trying to learn how to blend
in as part of a civilization like
sinister imposters among us well the
ones in foundation captivity seem to be
pretty eager to leave during multiple
incidents they have been known to create
shells that mimic the appearance of
security staff scientists and other
foundation personnel in order to
orchestrate their escape all the while
they've been showing themselves capable
of learning how to impersonate human
speech and mannerisms but what is it all
for the best answer is we don't know or
rather we don't know
yet could they be here to study humanity
do these
scp-3994s want to learn how to be more
like us for their own benefit think
about it if you had no shape no body if
you were just a formless mass wouldn't
you feel a little
lonely
scp-3994's like humans might be social
animals the difference is we can hug
each other high-five each other converse
form meaningful connections through
talking and touch it could be that's
where these extraterrestrial impostors
want why they decided to venture across
the stars to live among us that'd be
nice right but then there's the other
explanation
scp-3994 are an alien army hiding out on
earth learning more and more about us
day by day the more they learn the
better they'll get at copying us walking
talking and acting no different from any
other human the foundation doesn't even
know just how many are out there soon
they could have perfectly mimicked every
language every culture every person on
earth and what happens then what happens
when we all get replaced well at that
point the planet would no longer belong
to us it would be the new home for
scp-3994
now go check out
man eating bus and scp-939 with many
voices the complete story for more
anomalies that are hiding in plain sight